qualcomm paid out and received payment
of billions of dollars in settlement and
fines
uh there seems to be a lot of huge
lawsuits in the space how do you explain
that uh does
does this get in the way of innovation
or does it promote it
i will rephrase it by saying there used
to be a lot of lawsuits in the space
in addition of
of what we do in semiconductors you know
our processors and our our modems
snapdragon platform
we also have a licensing business which
has been a part of the company since the
beginning
as the largest
inventors of the essential technology in
2g cdma 3g 4g and 5g
uh you know and qualcomm contribute that
to the standards so we always had this
model that
rather than invent the technology and be
the only one producing the products we
license so everyone can produce it
and uh and as such we receive
intellectual property uh
for these standard essential patents
um
as part of our past
dispute with apple that's behind us now
your friends now they're they're
they're my customers um and and uh as
part of that i think the the licensing
model got tested in i think in every
geography
and uh we succeeded in every single
geography to validate
the pro competitiveness of this model i
think the uh the fair reasonable
non-discriminatory aspect of this model
and i would argue that besides being the
most successful licensing business to
date in the industry probably the one
that's been battle tested in this most
stable because there's not a single
jurisdiction that we have not uh headed
to validate that model so it's part of
our past and what it creates is probably
create a lot of stability in our
licensing business but having said that
the growth of the company is in the
semiconductor space and the
semiconductor so licensing is you come
up with a pretty good idea you have a
bunch of smart people coming up with
cool ideas
and then once you come up with that idea
you sell that idea to others they get to
use it that's essentially a license the
license revenue we have is is for the
what we call the scp standard essential
patents
that are part of
uh the 2g 3g 4g and 5g standards so if
you want to build anything with 5g
you need to get a license from qualcomm
because uses qualcomm uh essential
technology is part of the standard and a
slightly different model or a lot
different model the semiconductor is you
design
you inject a bunch of fascinating ideas
how to build the snapdragon and then
there's
because it's a fabulous company you have
somebody build
the the the the chip and then goes into
a phone with the branding and all that
kind of stuff and and that let has less
kind of players involved it's not a
license we sell the product in the
seminar we don't license semiconductor
technology we build products and we sell
products
you